did you know that several of your
favorite actors were almost cast in the
Harry Potter movies yeah I'm talking a
completely different Lord Voldemort
Hagrid and even Professor Dumbledore the
Harry Potter films as you know them are
about to be flipped totally upside down
this is one of the more well-known
potential castings but can you imagine
what the movies would have been like if
Ian McKellen was cast as Dumbledore
Richard Harris played the iconic
Headmaster in the first two Harry Potter
films but when he passed away Ian was
considered for his replacement Ian
McKellen was familiar with playing
Wizards as obviously he played Gandalf
in The Lord of the Rings I played the
real wizard so it seems like the obvious
choice unfortunately he did end up
turning down the role because he didn't
feel comfortable replacing Richard I
couldn't take over the part from an
actor who I'd known didn't approve him
the legendary Robin Williams was
actually rejected for two roles in the
Harry Potter World after Robin Williams
passed away it was revealed by the
casting director that he really wanted
to be in the movies as either Hagrid or
Lupine the reason and why he was
rejected is because they only wanted to
cast British actors in the film so the
role ended up going to JK Rowling's
first choice Robbie Coltrane it's crazy
that an actor could be too famous for a
role obviously we all know Kate Winslet
jumped into the Limelight after her
iconic role across Leonardo DiCaprio in
Titanic she starred alongside him again
in 2008 in the movie Revolutionary Road
and also won best actress that year for
her role in the reader casting was
seriously looking at her to play the
role of Helena Ravenclaw rowano
ravenclaw's daughter but rumor has it
that her agent thought the role was a
bit too small for her so the role went
to Kelly McDonald instead I definitely
know Tilda Swinton as the White Witch
from The Chronicles of Narnia so it
definitely doesn't seem like a shot in
the dark that she would play a role in
the Harry Potter films especially
because she also joined the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as the Ancient One in
Doctor Strange Tilda Swinton was
actually in consideration for the role
of Professor sir trelawny who runs
divination class surprisingly she ended
up turning the role down because she
doesn't like movies like Harry Potter I
mean totally valid the role ended up
going to Emma Thompson Hugh Grant is a
well-known actor having starred in
movies like Love Actually and Bridget
Jones Diary he first stepped onto the
scene in 1994 with the movie Four
Weddings and a funeral so needless to
say it would have been a pretty big deal
had he been in Harry Potter he was
pretty much one of the only people they
wanted to cast as Fielder Roy Lockhart
who first shows up in Harry Potter and
the Chamber of Secrets though he ended
up turning down the role because of
scheduling conflicts with another movie
he was filming two weeks notice
naturally the role ended up being given
to Kenneth Rana technically yes Eddie
Redmayne did land a spot in the Harry
Potter franchise with his lead role as
Newt scamander in the Fantastic Beasts
film series but did you know he actually
auditioned to play Tom Riddle yeah if
you don't remember Tom Riddle was a
Slytherin wizard who later becomes Lord
Voldemort apparently Eddie Redmayne
wanted that role and auditioned for it
but the audition went awful he never got
a call back and the role was given to
Christopher Coulson despite being 23 at
the time eventually though that did
catch up with him as he was deemed too
old to come back for Harry Potter and
the Half-Blood Prince so here's another
little Lord Voldemort tidbit for you
Rowan Atkinson who is most notably known
for his performance as Mr Bean in the
90s sitcom of the same name as well as
the voice of Zazu in The Lion King I've
Got a Lovely Bunch of Coconuts
auditioned to be he who must not be
named who we've already named many times
he was actually one of the final few who
were in consideration for the role it
was even rumored that he did in fact
land the role but was deemed too comedic
to actually play it the role ended up
going to Ray fines which was probably
the right decision in the end as Rowan
Atkinson is definitely too funny of a
guy sercia Ronan was literally nominated
for an Oscar at the young age of 13 for
her role in the movie Atonement it would
have been huge if she was actually cast
in Harry Potter the role she was up for
was Luna Lovegood which she was super
stoked about because she was a huge
Harry Potter fan at the time so I've
basically worked with half the Harry
Potter cast now I'm pretty impressed she
ended up being overlooked for the role
and it went to Ivana Lynch who is three
years older than her cersa later
admitted that of course she was
disappointed she didn't get the role But
ultimately she was way too young to play
it while all of these casting decisions
were totally valid Too Young Too Old too
funny and not British enough I can't
help but imagine a completely new Harry
Potter franchise with every single one
of these actors cast in the role they
auditioned for which one of these actors
would you have liked to see in the Harry
Potter movies